let's say that you're on some type of a
game show and you've been doing quite
well and you're now at the round where
you get to pick your fantabulous
vacation and so there are three possible
places that you could go
you could go on an island Beach vacation
island Island Beach vacation you could
go skiing on a ski vacation or you could
go camping now those aren't the only
possibilities because for each of those
vacations there's different amount of
time that you could go on them
so you could go for one day you could go
for two days two days or you could go
for three days three is in a different
color you could go for three days you
could go for three days so the first
question I did want to know is well what
is the and it's going they're going to
randomly pick either you know of a
one-day ski vacation or a two-day island
vacation but the first question I want
to know is what are all of the possible
outcomes here what is the sample space
what is the space from which we are
going to pick your particular vacation
package well for the sample space we can
construct a grid which you could see
that I've essentially been constructing
while I wrote down all of the
possibilities so let me draw out the
sample space with these uneven looking
grid lines all right I think you get the
picture
all right so you could go and I'll just
abbreviate it you could go on a one day
a one day island a one day island trip
this one I this is one day island trip
you could go on a two day to day
actually let me just write it this way
all of these are going to be one day
right because on the one day column all
of these are going to be two days two
days two days and all of these are going
to be three days because it's on the
three day column and all of the ones in
this row are going to be island trips so
it's a one day island trip
to day island trip three day island trip
this second roads all ski trips one day
ski trip two-day ski trip
three days key trip and then finally
everything in this third row there are
camping trips one day camping trip two
day camping trip three-day camping trip
so just like that we have constructed to
the sample space right over here you see
that there's one two three four five six
seven eight nine outcomes and let's say
that each of these outcomes are a little
piece of paper and they put it in a
barrel and they roll it up and for our
purposes we can assume that they are all
equally likely outcomes so we're going
to assume equally likely outcomes so if
we do assume equally likely outcomes we
can figure out a probability may be you
know may you live in someplace that's
cold and you're really not in the mood
to go skiing in fact you'd like to spend
several days away from the snow so let's
ask ourselves a question what is the
probability what is the probability that
you're going to win something at least
at least two days on a vacation without
snow two days on vacation without
without snow you're going to randomly
pick one of these nine outcomes what's
the probability that it's going to be at
least it's going to give you a vacation
that gives you at least of a case with
two days without snow well let's just
think a little bit about it we know the
sample space and we know each of the
outcomes are equally likely there are
nine equally equal outcomes here so
let's write that down we got nine equal
outcomes now how many of the SAC
outcomes satisfy this this event this
this this constraint at least two day
two days of a vacation I mean two day
let me write this two days days without
snow whether it falls or touching it or
whatever so this is you're essentially
avoiding skiing you want at least two
days on something other than skiing and
we're assuming you're not going to go
camping in some type of Alpine you're
camping in someplace that's warm well
let's think about these outcomes so this
one is no snow but it's only one day
this is two days without snow so we can
circle
one this is three days without snow so
we can circle that one all of these have
snow this is one day without snow so
we're not going to do this one this is
two days without snow and this is three
days without snow and so four of the
equally likely outcomes satisfy this
constraint so you have a 4/9 probability
of getting a be getting a vacation that
keeps you away from snow for at least
two days hopefully found that fun and
useful for the next time that you are on
some type of strange game show